our institutions not just politics but
media creative Industries cultural
institutions universities schools are
now in the hands of a new middle class
graduate Elite who hold values that are
simply very different from the values
that are held by millions of people out
there
I polled them and said look you know
what do you think about this you know
the s p are trying to pass it everyone
looked at it and said this is insane
eighty percent of people say I oppose
this instantly when you actually explain
what it is I mean the level of
disillusionment out there
is palpable you see it right you see it
feel it the reservoir of disillusionment
the fact that everybody is sort of just
out there saying none of these people
really represent me none of these people
speak for me speak for my values
represent my voice we're talking about a
level of demographic change and churn
that the Brits have not seen before and
it's going to be very very visible
very very quick
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today returns
to the show for the 700th time a is a
political scientist and one of our
favorites he's got a new book out which
is this book here values voice and
virtue Matthew good and welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having me
welcome back we have had you on the show
a lot this is my third time is it yeah
yeah it feels like more because we
really we you you always provide
fantastic commentary on on British and
other politics yeah uh and we always
bump into each other at various events
that we do
um it's actually your fourth time man
sorry maybe the one in the aftermath of
the 2019 election was like a bit of a
blur so maybe I forgot that one yeah so
we've done a few but my point is we're
always really interested to hear your
take on things yeah in addition to your
books you you have a fantastic sub stack
that I read religiously actually I read
yours too uh thank you
um do you have one no
because
this will go out a few weeks after we
record it but today your sub stack was
about post uh post populism yeah and
this is also something you touch on in
the book of course and this is something
I'm very interested in talking about
because you uh first of all Define for
us what you mean by post populism and
where is it happening and why is it
happening so I guess one of the things
I've tried to do in the book is say we
just had this remarkable decade which
has basically overturned a lot of the
things we thought we knew about British
politics we had in my mind at least we
had these three big revolts we had the
rise of Nigel farage and populism I know
you had Nigel on the show recently we
then had the big vote for brexit and
then we had the Boris Johnson 2019
election and that sort of post-brexit
realignment of politics so in my mind
actually what we've gone through is a
sort of Trilogy of Acts and in the book
what I've tried to do is say look where
did these come from what on Earth made
all of that possible and the short
answer is that I argue we've got
millions of people out there who are
holding values that are basically not
shared by this new Elite in our country
but given where we are today I do think
that you know we are probably beginning
now to see the emergence of what we
might call the sort of post-populism era
so
um you know all of the leaders from the
2019 election Boris Johnson Jeremy
corbyn Nicholas sturgeon Nigel farage
have either been pushed out or they're
lying low we've got the technocrats the
grown-ups the managers back in charge
we've got Kia stama we've got Rishi Suna
we've got a new consensus in politics
I'm sure many of your viewers will have
their own opinion about it but big state
big spending High immigration embracing
globalization there's no really uh
longer any difference between left and
right anymore they're basically
indistinguishable and voters I mean
they're not basically being pushed apart
by big divisive issues in the way that
they once were Firehouse voters in my
polls what do you care about the most
they say cost of living the NHS and the
economy I mean these are more sort of
unifying issues we all care about those
issues so in my mind you know raises
this question are we actually leaving
the era of populism in the 2010s are we
moving in to you know this new era of
post-populism and what's that going to
look like and I know you've talked about
post-woke what does the post-woke era
look like in the same way I think we are
entering into potentially a new a new
chapter it's an interesting point though
because uh simultaneously with the shift
and the Politics as you alluded to and
your answer there the fact is people
haven't changed how they feel about it
and so the the fishes that that were
expressed through brexit uh and by the
way Donald Trump in America and the
Raging culture wars that is still going
on absolutely in a very powerful way so
I'm almost questioning of your thesis
Matt only in the sense that we've lived
through this period of our six or seven
years where every time and Francis is
the Perpetual pessimist and I'm the
perpetual and every time finally all
this crap is over something new happens
and things just get crazier and crazier
whether it's the summer of BLM whether
it's covered in our reaction sure what
suddenly a war breaks out in the middle
of Europe and people have got all sorts
of you know ways of looking at that yeah
and I'm sort of thinking if if the
underlying disagreements within the the
body politics are still there aren't we
just waiting for another thing to go
wrong and then there's going to be
another big explosion yeah I mean in my
mind the Big Challenge we have in our
society like all Western democracies is
what I call in the book the new Elite
that we are basically in a situation now
where our institutions not just politics
but media creative Industries cultural
institutions universities schools are
now in the hands of a new middle class
graduate Elite uh who hold values that
are simply very different from the
values that are held by millions of
people out there and one of the things I
try and argue in the book at least is
that you know it's not just over the 10
last 10 years this new Elite have sort
of drifted away from everybody else and
they've taken the institutions with them
it's also that they openly exclude the
voice of other groups Society workers
people who haven't passed through the
elite universities people who hold let's
say contrarian beliefs maybe people who
question the woke Orthodoxy or the
radical Progressive Outlook that
dominates the institutions and that is
why people have been turning to these
revolts because they've been saying look
hang on a minute I want to reassert my
values I want to reassert my belief
system I want to reassert my voice in
the National conversation because I
don't really feel that people like me
are in this conversation and I think
that's basically what's been happening
over the last decade I think the
evidence shows that quite clearly and
whether it's Nigel farage whether it's
Boris Johnson whether it's the
brexiteers whoever you know for many
voters these were imperfect leaders for
those moments
um but but out there you know we've got
you know large majorities of people who
are saying look left and right don't
really speak to me anymore on these
issues that you mention around cult
culture and identity what we're teaching
kids in school borders security
Community a lot of Voters are still
saying they don't speak for me anymore
and I think you know we're maybe not
over populism but I think we're we're
sort of into in a we're in a
brief phase perhaps between moments
um and we can at least maybe take stock
of the last decade and
um you know I'm sure we'll be back there
maybe sometime soon isn't it quite
dangerous so if you think about it
because what you're essentially talking
about now is this large swipe of the
population who are not represented by
politicians yeah well so one of the
things that I
um show is that
um most of our politicians lean much
further to the cultural left and much
further to the economic right than most
voters out there so conservatives why if
conservatives responded so terribly to
the realignment of politics and we
talked about this after 2019 I remember
the conversation vividly we said there
is a unique historic opportunity here
for Boris Johnson and the conservatives
to reshape the country
and they squandered that opportunity
they lost that opportunity why did they
I would suggest as I argue in the book
is that because conservative Elites
basically are too culturally liberal and
too economically liberal to connect with
the voters who are looking for somebody
to reassert their values in the system
and so all we've really had since brexit
is a continuation of what you might call
the liberal consensus which is basically
dominated British politics for much of
the last 30 40 years Margaret Thatcher
you know was needed I'm I'm open to I
accept the idea that you know Thatcher's
reforms in my mind at the time they were
needed but what she did is she injected
this radical economic liberalism
deregulated uh the economy liberalized
Finance Embrace globalization or what
Danny Roderick has called hyper
globalization the routine prioritization
of big business of big corporates over
the national community and that was
followed by Blair and Blair then came
along and he injected radical cultural
liberalism he said hey we're going to
strip away the borders of the national
Community we're gonna have mass
immigration we're going to have European
integration we're going to take
meaningful Choice out of politics left
and right are essentially going to
become the same thing brexit populism
the realignment were really an attempt
by voters to break that consensus to
challenge that consensus and what we can
now see is that actually uh those
revolts have failed to do that and that
the elite the new graduate Elite
socially liberal if not radically
Progressive has reasserted its political
and cultural power uh and push back uh
that that Rebellion do you think that
part of the reason why things aren't as
heated anymore is because of the brexit
referendum yet we look at countries like
Italy like Spain and they are very much
still in the throes of populism yeah I
think it's remarkable that Britain now
is one of the only Western democracies
to not have a successful populist
movement and when I wrote my last book
National populism a lot of people were
critical they said well these movements
are going to be a flash in the pan
they're going to rapidly disappear look
at the elections last year France Sweden
Spain Portugal Italy Hungary record
levels of support for National populist
parties meanwhile the Republicans fell
short in the U.S but they took back the
house Ronda santis now or Trump probably
have a realistic chance of winning the
presidency uh uh next year so populism
is still here but in Britain bizarrely
it's it's absent and the reason for that
is because the conservatives basically
hoovered up Nigel farage's vote they
hoovered up a lot of these voices who
took a pump on on Boris Johnson and they
said look if you're going to be the guy
that's going to shake up this consensus
if you're going to deliver brexit if
you're going to reform immigration if
you're going to push back against the
woke
um we're going to give you a chance and
what happened Johnson basically let them
down Johnson
did the reverse on a lot of that stuff I
mean one of the untold stories about
British politics today which I don't
think many people out there have yet
realized is the extent to which Boris
Johnson and the conservatives
liberalized the immigration system in
Britain to the point that we now have
000 uh uh uh as a net migration
um level the highest we've we've ever
had uh just to make the point they
promised that it would go down David
Cameron promised to the tens of
thousands yeah so what's happened is
British conservatives Boris Johnson
Dominic Cummings and others have been
gaslighting the British people because
what they've been saying is we're going
to control immigration we're going to
lower immigration and then when they
ended up in power they said well
actually we didn't mean lower we just
meant we're going to give you control
uh but what is clear I'm running polls
every week most people out there want
immigration lowered end of story ideally
around 100 000 certainly not five
hundred thousand and worst bit of all of
it is Johnson not only liberalizes
migration to this unprecedented extent
but he even does stuff like removes the
requirement for British companies to
advertise jobs in Britain so what you
see contrary to the um the desire
through the brexit vote to put the
national Community First is you
basically see conservatives perhaps best
symbolized by Liz Truss
kind of doubling down on this hyper
globalization Mass immigration
london-centric model built around
Financial Services uh and basically
putting their fingers up at many of the
voters who turned to them in 2019 and
thought well gee maybe these are the
people that are going to break up the
consensus so I suspect that the real
winner at the next election won't
actually be the labor party in kierstama
it would be apathy it would be a lot of
people saying you know what I try to
change a system I try to regain my voice
I try to reassert my values nobody's
interested Matt we had Nigel Freud
sitting in that very seat a few weeks
back and he actually said that the
reason
that popular is not that it felt but it
didn't achieve what it could have
achieved and in particular ukip was
because of the because of the two-party
system which is impossible to break yeah
do you think part of the reason that
populism founded is because of that and
if you look at our European friends they
all tend to have a proportional
representation that's part of the story
and I've spent a long time following
um
faraja's movement and I've written about
it in one of the first books that I did
was about it and you know the European
Parliament elections under a
proportional system with a springboard
that he shrewdly used in 1999 to to get
visibility and then one of the ironies
of brexit is that a moment that was
supposed to lead to the reform of our
politics made our politics more elitist
because it took away the European
Parliament election so the only way you
can change the system now is through
first Pastor post-general elections
which is an impossible thing to do or
build up through local elections which
has been the liberal Democrat strategy
for 50 years and they'll tell you how
difficult that is and that's why I mean
only last last week in early 23 I was in
a meeting with conservatives who are now
beginning to realize the only way
they can actually bring about meaningful
change within the British system is to
change the dominant faction within the
conservative party which is to basically
spark an internal battle with liberal
conservatives
or self-styled Progressive conservatives
and to try and reassert the power of
what we might call National
conservatives and to reshape the
conservative party from within like they
are saying now that is the only way they
will be able to to assert power and and
change the direction of the party and
for faraj and and others who are who who
on the outside I mean the reality now is
they are probably consigned to taking
five to ten percent of the vote at the
next election making life much more
difficult for Richie sunac if they want
to do that but the games become a lot
harder the barriers to entry have become
a lot higher for for the likes of farage
So You Don't See reform coming in and
then taking a chunk and holding the the
conservatives feat to the fire to
actually get them to be more
conservative it's going to be very very
difficult for them because
um
I think it's going to be difficult for
them for a couple of reasons but one is
that I personally don't think that the
populace in Britain ever truly
understood the constituency that was
wanting to to vote for them culturally
they were in the right space they were
saying look our approach on crime is a
joke immigration is too lacks the
institutions are disproportionately
dominated by Elite graduates who
basically hold values that nobody else
in the country really holds so on the
culture stuff they were basically where
they needed to be on the economic axis
however a lot of them were basically
factorized were basically focused on
lowering tax deregulating Financial
Services being fairly comfortable with
big business now if you look at the
Republicans in the US if you look at
Maloney in Italy if you look at what's
happening in France or Sweden actually
the nature of conservative politics is
changing you know some conservatives
today have grasped the fact that they
cannot simply offer an anti-state low
tax pro-business message that that the
world has moved on and so National
conservatives are saying the time is now
here to make the case for an active
state that can intervene in uh the
economy to make things fairer that is
skeptical of business especially when
business becomes political especially
when business starts to promote values
of the scene to be anti-conservative and
which
um is much more realistic about
globalization and free trade I mean this
is one of the things I talk about in the
book is how basically thatcherites
um became so obsessed with free trade
and globalization that they lost sight
of the damage it was doing in
communities I mean globalization wasn't
just negative for economic reasons I
mean the evidence is pretty clear it's
smash communities in areas in northern
England that were subjected to higher
imports from China or Eastern Europe the
result was not just lower wages was not
just a lower share of the national
income going going to those areas it was
also weaker relationships higher rates
of family breakdown higher rates of
alcoholism drug addiction people being
pushed onto welfare benefits now
conservatives I thought you know care
about community care about family but
too often I meet conservatives who
routinely prioritize
the market and globalization and free
trade over these issues around community
and family and and I think if you look
at just how much territory conservatives
have ceded over the last 10 years
you can see that quite clearly I mean
essentially
conservatives have allowed
issues such as family
Children's Welfare women's rights
history and national identity to be
reframed as culture wars
I mean it is one of the biggest retreats
in recent political history they've
completely
lost all of that territory and they're
now on the defensive and are having to
make the case for why
um we should be allowed
to talk about what we teach kids or
whether we should be allowed to feel
uncomfortable with kids being exposed to
drag queens or whatever it is so they're
completely you know lost lost
um lost that lost that space which again
goes to show
um how I think they've been far too
focused on on these issues like
globalization free trade Matt can we
come back to the economics of this
because I mean as you know I'm not
conservative but on the economic side of
it I'm always very very persuaded by
small state as as an as an idea because
my concern is and we've seen it with you
know we're seeing these lockdown files
coming out yeah the bigger the
government the more the you know the
government can you know they'll give you
money but they're also going to tell you
what to do a lot and I really don't want
that as much as as it can be avoided but
am I right in thinking that I'm
basically in the wrong country for that
well for that world view to ever get a
fair Hearing in terms of the national
political conversation is is there any
instituency of people in this country
who'd quite like to
you know make make the best of life for
themselves
um there is a constituency for that I
mean let's take for example the Liz
truss world view let's have a small
state low tax and let's roll back the
Frontiers uh of government
um when when Liz trust was in power I
looked at the at the data on her
position and concluded it was kind of
like a six to ten percent of the
population uh position roughly about six
to ten percent were holding that kind of
trussite view
um in Britain most people today are
actually pretty comfortable with the
state with spending on as as we are with
big spending on the NHS with public
services you know the libertarian
instincts if you want to call it that
are actually very Fringe you know this
is not a mainstream position
um but I just wanted to be clear about
something so when I say National
conservatives need to revise their
relationship with the state what I'm not
saying is that National conservatives
should be suddenly pro-government and
have State what I mean is I think is an
acceptance on the right of global
politics now that they are going to have
to use the state in order to intervene
in institutions in the marketplace to
protect and preserve their values so an
example might be a Rhonda santis in
Florida using the organs of the state to
intervene to try and rectify how we
teach kids certain issues or it might be
the UK government intervening using the
state to create a mechanism whereby
academics and those people who hold
non-conformist views who maybe are
gender critical or you know don't want
to go along with the woke Orthodoxy that
they don't get sacked they don't get
discriminated against so I think that
debate now about you know conservatives
using the state in order to try and
intervene has become much more much more
prominent you won't meet many mainstream
us Republicans today a who are
advocating a Reagan type view of the
world conservativism is changing in big
ways in important ways I know you had
joram has only on the show and you know
he's often made that that very argument
Matt aren't we really just talking about
the political system no longer Being Fit
for purpose if it doesn't represent the
people that it it should then quite
frankly what's the point well I think
the issue and I talk a lot in this about
the book The issue is that the
institutions have basically been taken
over by new middle class graduates who
tend to come from privileged families
and share the same values this isn't a
conspiracy what we are seeing is what
academics call education polarization so
graduates have gradually graduates have
moved sharply leftwards and
non-graduates are basically moving
rightwards or staying where they are on
cultural issues so much isn't that fair
though saying moving gradually leftwards
because what in some cases over the last
10 years they've moved very quickly to
the left the so-called great awokening
where white liberals noticeably in the
US have doubled down on their liberalism
they basically become super woke so they
have become much more convinced racism
is a major problem that
African-Americans and other minority
groups are being discriminated against
and they've become more concerned about
those issues than minority groups okay
so this great awokening is really
important because if those same groups
disproportionately dominate institutions
they've taken the institutions with them
too which is where we can see the
debates about the New York Times the BBC
and others because these institutions
have now really become such an echo
chamber they've become so narrow in the
range of voices that are included within
them that if you're working class if you
haven't gone to University if you come
from the small towns medium towns well
outside of London if you hold culturally
conservative small C values on issues
like crime immigration of sex and gender
britishness who we are you are probably
looking at our advertisements at our
museums at our political debates at the
bestseller lists in the bookshops and
our writers and our celebrities and
you're probably thinking
what the hell's going on because they
are reflecting the values of this new
Elite they're not reflecting the values
of the rest of the country and Matt is
there a you know because it's very hard
to judge these things because those of
us who are quote unquote very online
people uh we see I think perhaps a
slightly different side of it is do you
see in your in your polling and in your
research a sort of backlash forming
against all of this or is that a
uniquely online phenomenon well I'm
interested I mean what what what do you
see differently I'm just curious as to
how what what what's the side that you
see that uh well what I see is an
increasing and it's interesting because
a lot of people won't wouldn't have
expected this but we just had Lawrence
Fox on the show and when we asked them
our final question which is what's the
one thing we're not talking about is
that the workification of the right and
I do see a lot of that online where
people who oppose wokeness are now
starting to feel that the only way to
deal with the problem is to to become
the thing that they're fighting to
cancel people to to get offended by
words to try and you know prevent
certain conversation from even being had
to Etc now this could be a completely
online thing that we're not seeing but I
but that is the sort of thing that I'm
talking about yeah I haven't seen too
much of that but I think there's
certainly a lot of evidence to suggest
that conservatives and center-right
parties have not really known what to do
with this moment and you can see that
very clearly with the British
conservatives I mean they have
floundered they have completely failed
to understand where voters are on many
of these issues take Scotland as an
example right we are we're talking
against the backdrop of the fall of
Nicola sturgeon and uh what a remarkable
uh week that was in in British politics
um and you know what was interesting is
before that everybody said to me you
know this culture War stuff
doesn't matter doesn't make a difference
nobody cares about it it's all generated
by right-wing culture Warriors and
nobody's interested then you look at the
gender recognition Reform Bill that was
brought by the SMP and it's true that
was not a highly Salient issue a lot of
Voters said you know this isn't a top
five issue for me but then when I polled
them and said look you know what do you
think about this you know the s p are
trying to pass it everyone looked at it
and said this is insane 80 of people say
I oppose this instantly when you
actually explain what it is let's let 16
year olds legally change their gender
without any medical supervision let's
let kids change their gender after
living in that new gender for only a
couple of weeks you know mums and dads
were like looking at this thinking this
is insane and the moment you actually
put these woke issues in front of people
and they really think about it you begin
to see the scale of the opposition to it
another example is let's rename pregnant
women pregnant persons that's a five
percent issue meaning only five percent
of the country think that's a good idea
right so I've been just polling all of
these little these policies that that we
associate with wokism and the key point
is if you look at the US the lesson is
for politicians who want to step into
those debates and want to politicize
those debates and want to turn up the
volume on those debates as we've seen in
Virginia California Florida
there is an ample market big market for
that for the space that exists for that
it's not a culture War talking about the
rights of kids talking about women's
rights it's not a cultural matters
really matters people want to have a
discussion about it so I think that's
where our debate has has uh has gone a
little bit wrong and why conservatives
you know have just shot themselves in
the foot because they've not really
acknowledged where people are on a lot
of these issues and you know we talk a
lot about kemi bad knock and we talk
about you know these individuals who
perhaps we think do have a sense but in
reality the whole conservative party
should understand
this it shouldn't be this this hard to
convince a conservative party to to get
involved in these debates we're talking
about the conservative party but as it
stands now labor stand a very good
chance of winning the next election
particularly when you see what's coming
out with the telegraphs and the you know
the lockdown files Etc it's only going
to weaken the conservatives chance of
winning
so that being the case things are only
going to get worse aren't they well the
labor party uh is having a really good
time uh averaging just close to 50 in
the polls
um doing really well
um you ask voters who do you want to be
prime minister uh kirstan was the head
of Rishi sunak who do you want to manage
the economy Labor's ahead of
conservatives who do want to manage
immigration Labor's ahead of
brexit Labor's ahead of conservatives
but here's the thing
um who's ahead of all of them none of
them none of the above I mean the level
of disillusionment out there
is palpable
you see it right you see it feel it the
reservoir of disillusionment the fact
that everybody is sort of just out there
saying none of these people really
represent me none of these people speak
for me speak for my values represent my
voice I was running focus groups in the
red wall a couple of weeks ago
and uh I sort of said you know okay so
how do you feel about how the country's
going first 20 minutes everybody
screaming at the conservatives can't
stand the conservatives want the
conservatives out of power you know so
you're going to be voting labor well um
not sure what about Kirsten who not sure
who is that guy don't really know him
there's still a disconnect I think
between labor and the country and I
think there are two areas where people
are suspicious of Labor one is can labor
manage the economy and the other is can
labor manage immigration and and those
two issues obviously really matter for
people sunac is sort of cultivating an
image if you talk to people around
sooner they'll say is cultivating an
image as the quiet prime minister who's
getting things done you know he's
delivering in Scotland he's standing up
to Nicola sturgeon he's delivering in
Northern Ireland he's got the brexit
deal he's bringing legislation for the
small boats he's gambling that inflation
will fall from 10 to below five percent
by the end of the year and then interest
rates Begin to Fall the cost of living
will ease he'll go into 24 and he'll say
to people you know we're we're turning
the corner don't let the labor party
ruin it that will be the sort of you
know the narrative
um but I still every time I talk about
sunak and the conservatives and you can
see it in the data there's a great
degree of skepticism and there's a great
degree of apathy you know I think people
are just frustrated utterly frustrated
with the political class and it goes
back to what I what I talk about in the
book I mean we've never really had a
political class that has been this
dominated
by people from particular groups I mean
University graduates and political
careerists
um people who have only ever worked in
politics I mean we've always had an
elite in Britain but you know in the old
days
um the elite also typically went into
politics having done other things you
know different jobs different different
things you know running companies being
out there today I think that's that's
less the case and so this the political
class in my book has become much more
homogeneous much more uniform very
narrow the ranger voices in Parliament
the range of voices in the media in our
culture has become much narrower and
maybe as you say maybe you're right
maybe the conversation really is
happening online uh rather than in the
in the Public Square in the main Arena
and Matt this dominance by a particular
world view if we assume that labor are
going to win the next election which is
not guaranteed when we interviewed David
Davis the other day he said I'm very
optimistic I think we have gone from 1
and 10 to one and five and I went well
it's still twenty percent so even
conservatives don't necessarily feel
very confident about the chat their
party's chances but let's assume that
labor doing isn't this actually a much
bigger problem for kirst armor because
that Elite of the middle class educated
people they are going to be expecting
him and to come in and deliver on all of
their work priorities and I don't think
he's going to be able to do that without
sparking a major Rebellion with the
country at large I think you saw that in
the reaction to Scotland I mean to his
credit storm has said look I think
allowing 16 year olds to legally change
their gender is not the is not the way
to go
um Lisa and Andy followed up shortly
afterwards saying we should allow 13
year olds
exactly yeah but that's a serious point
so I mean that we we have entered a
politics where the the activist space
has become dominated by the sort of
Brahmin left the high High income Highly
Educated not just socially liberal but
radically Progressive activists and that
is severely constraining where left-wing
parties can go and they're also
constrained by geography I mean one of
the problems facing labor is most of
their votes are still concentrated in
the cities and the university towns
which is why starmus going to have to
make some Headway in non-land England
unless they can get big gains now in
Scotland which would offset that and to
do that he needs to talk to voters still
about the cultural Dimension now when he
came out recently and said I've got five
missions which is interesting because
Rishi sunak said he's got five tests so
you've got you know these big five
pledges on both sides
um starma didn't mention immigration at
all didn't mention small boats talked
about crime a little bit like Blair
tough on crime tough on the causes of
crime but I do think labor still have
left the big open goal for the
conservatives if the conservatives were
smart enough to kick up ball into it
they probably would have a chance
um because I think this issue is only
going to become more important
especially as the cost of living crisis
Fades from View and it will do I mean
fast forward to mid-2020s late 2020s
um you know we get through
let's hope the war in Ukraine
um the energy crisis we begin to get
back to some sense of normality and then
I think people are going to realize that
the pace of change in Britain because of
the things that have been Unleashed uh I
think they're going to find that very
very difficult very challenging
um we're talking about a level of
demographic change and churn that the
Brits have not seen before and it's
going to be very very visible very very
quick
um and that's going to raise all kinds
of political effects uh before we go any
further I just want to say I think it's
quite unfair at least in Andy was only
reflecting her constituency of Wigan and
their opinions
yeah but isn't part of the problem as
well is that you look at these major
political parties conservative labor and
essentially they are a union of people
who in many ways believe completely
different things if you look at the old
school left of Labor typified by let's
say you know uh Tony Ben Barbara Castle
and then you look at ashaka that is a
union which doesn't really work because
they believe completely different things
and the same with the conservative party
where you've got the work Progressive
conservatives and then you've got the
old school conservatives the one nation
tourists sure so yeah I mean does it
work anymore well I mean
politics has become politics has moved
into a very different
era a different chapter I mean the the
first century of politics was was
primarily economic it was mainly left
and right now politics has become
two-dimensional culture and identity
have really come into this and cross
over that economic access so parties
have been you know facing these
cross-cutting divides and it's not been
easy because we're also in a
majoritarian first Pastor post system we
don't have proportional representation
where the conservatives would be two
parties a labor party would be two
parties maybe three parties
um so they're all forced to coexist
uneasily
um and that's not an easy thing to do I
mean labor and the conservatives
basically were born against the backdrop
of the Industrial Revolution I mean they
have been shaped by a history that is
very different from where we are now and
they've been struggling to adapt to this
new climate if you look across Europe
many of the parties that have been
really successful recently have been
entirely new parties that have been much
more flexible much more able to speak to
the constituencies today without those
constraints you know you look at whether
it's macron whether it's Maloney you
know these parties are you know pretty
new flexible and can take on you know
the the Monopoly
um we don't really have that and our
system makes it much harder so the
challenge is going to be whether
the people who are within those parties
can change the dominant factions within
them and can they actually try and
reposition them uh you know in in an
important way and it does happen I mean
the US Republicans would be an example
of that I'm not saying the British
conservatives should become a trump
Champion party but the U.S Republicans
have fundamentally changed their access
right they've moved into a very
different space it is possible for
parties to do that maybe we're at a
point now where both labor and the
conservatives need to need to adapt and
readjust to to this new reality of where
we are
you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
if you think as well we're going to see
a rise of the hard right as typified by
Marie Le Pen who did very well in the
French general election I don't think
people were aware or of how well she
actually did and what a threat she posed
to macron do you think we're going to
see that in the UK I don't think we are
no I think one of the things I've talked
about in the book is the restoration of
our Civic culture and it's worth it's
worth remembering what what is it that
makes Britain different from the French
and the Germans and the Italians and one
of the arguments from the 50s is that we
have a very different political culture
and we do I mean we it's we need to
remember this I mean you know we have
historically prioritized consensus over
conflict we prioritize moderation over
Messianic figures we have prioritized
politeness over polarization and that
was one of the big arguments in the 50s
why is it that Germany descended into
Nazism Italy descended into fascism
Spain and Portugal would descend into
authoritarianism why is it that the
breadth have never really done that you
know the British Union of fascists went
nowhere I mean Mosley never never won a
seed the national front in the 70s never
won a seat in the first pass the
post-selection the BMP never came close
to winning a seat
um uh so so so you know we have had a
very different politics and the argument
is not just about the system it is about
our culture that we have historically
put an emphasis on this Civic culture
and I do think maybe that is beginning
to return in some way that I after the
last decade the polarization The
Division I think you know maybe you know
the Brits are returning to that culture
and maybe saying you know what okay
there are these loony worksters on
Twitter and these these Nutters over
here but actually
um the moderate middle you know
um is perhaps beginning to say I'm just
just tired of of this Division I want to
I want to return to some sense of
normality well that is why I talked as
you mentioned about the post woke yeah
and how how that comes about and that
will take new institutions and
ecosystems and I'm very hopeful and I
hope that what you're saying is correct
the the one challenge to to what you and
I are both saying I suppose is the
extent to which our culture is now
dominated by American culture yeah and
all it takes is the Big Orange menace to
run which he will of course of course he
will he's about to the primaries are
starting yeah soon yeah and I mean God
only knows what happens then right and
then before you know it we've got all
the same crap here in the UK I don't
think we well I don't think we could
ever have a a trumpian no I don't mean
that but culturally will and poor or
like Sadiq Khan spends more during the
Trump era spend more time talking about
Trump than he did about London right the
mayor of London so so you get into this
place where the we did download a lot of
that I moved out of London
couldn't deal with anything so did I I
don't blame you couldn't deal with it
but but you know what I'm saying right
we download a lot of our cultural
conversation from of course yeah and
they are gonna get even more polarized
especially the Elite Class yes you know
and and the reality I think is white
graduate liberals in Britain have sort
of co-opted the same belief system as
their counterparts in the US and and
it's important to try and think why is
that why is that the case why have they
done that well the main reason I think
is because wokism has become a new
status system for this new graduate
Elite it has become a new source of
status of moral righteousness and it's
it's become a system that the elite can
use to send a signal to other Elites
that they are virtuous they are
righteous they've got the vocabulary to
show off the new knowledge to show
people they went to the right schools
and the right universities it's
cisgender heteronormative white guilt
White Privilege I mean it comes with
this whole vocabulary it is as John but
water and others have noted it is
essentially a new religion for the for
the new Elite and and along the way I I
don't think voters are idiots I think
they can see that and I think they can
sense that there's a new moral hierarchy
in society and and guess what they're
not at the top of it you know and and
the way in which the elite project this
now you know in the old days it was
money it was Leisure it was going on
holiday it was showing off fashion now
it is it is very much about showing off
their their sense of virtue and it's a
deeply narcissistic belief system I mean
it is a very
um sort of inward looking kind of
self-righteous belief system
um that that inevitably entails looking
down on those other groups that you now
perceive to be morally inferior and the
evidence on this which I talk about in
the book is is now clear that you know
reason a reason labor lost a lot of
white working-class voters over the last
decade is because those voters came to
the conclusion that labor was
prioritizing minority groups over the
majority
um you look at the US similar Studies
have found Trump did very well among uh
white non-graduate Americans who felt uh
had a keen sense that they had been
pushed to the bottom of the social
ladder or that to quote one study
minorities were basically cutting in
line for the American dream you know
there was this sense that they were Now
sort of being pushed down this ladder
simply because of their fixed group
identity and I think that's what Michael
sandel has called the politics of
humiliation and I think a lot of people
out there can feel that and it's very
visceral
um you know the recent study a recent
report from Cambridge found that now we
have universities that are offering
courses only to children from Minority
ethnic families and not offering them to
White working class kids you know people
read this they pick up on this and they
have a I think they conclude that you
know they're they're no longer seen by
the elite as being virtuous and morally
righteous so coming back to my question
are you not concerned that sorry did I
not answer your questions but that's
fine it was a great answer to the
different question which we love but my
question to you is this if the culture
War and the actual political discussion
gets re-inflamed as it will do in the
United States I agree with you are we
not going to take that and download it
over here and and the example I always
use because it just if I found it
mind-boggling but also illustrates the
point very well is the summer of 2020
when in central London you have
protesters saying hands up don't shoot
the police officers who don't have guns
and and to me that is the encapsulation
of just how much we are infected with
everything that comes out of the United
States I degree I mean I think there is
a lot of that and I think Trump too
would would again put that on steroids I
mean the great awokening you know the
kind of sharp leftward turn among white
white graduate liberals basically
tracked the Trump presidency it kind of
began it began in 2012 2013 but then
accelerated through the Trump presidency
and I think we had something similar
here with brexit I think if you look at
the folks who dominate the national
conversation the BBC presenters the
columnists the editors and so forth the
kind of new middle class graduate Elite
became much more supportive much more
positive about immigration diversity all
of those things in the aftermath of
brexit uh so it's what academics have
sometimes called the populist Paradox on
the one hand Britain becomes more
populous on the other hand we become way
more socially liberal why is that well
one big reason is because the graduate
Elite basically doubled down they
doubled down on their own values and
they kind of kind of went off a cliff
with a lot of this stuff and so I think
um there is a very real risk that that
culturally they'll they'll continue to
embrace what we see in America
absolutely but I think that's also
partly inflamed by social media and the
fact that a lot of people don't read
anymore they're sort of we're all just
out there with no attention span and
we're just you know reading
International media we're in the shared
online space
um and we're very ignorant of historical
context so a lot of people in the debate
in the UK around race and slavery and
discrimination you know you often hear
will sort of lapse into this belief that
we are somehow comparable to US History
which is crazy I mean it's insane and
Nigel bigger's book and I know you've
got Nigel coming on the show you know he
does a very good job of explaining just
the difference between the two but we
are now at a point in our cultural
debate but we have to explain this to
people we have to say actually we have
completely different histories we have
completely different Institute
institutions we have a very different
history when it comes to race
integration uh when it comes to
Prejudice we are actually one of the
least prejudiced Societies in the world
um the evidence I think is quite clear
on that I talk about it in the book but
for the kind of white graduate liberals
that is you know Blasphemous that's
that's heretic I mean I'm a heretic for
saying that because it challenges the
new Creed it challenges a new belief
system but isn't that a failure of
Education as well Matt because you you
can you know blame the kids blame the
young people all you want but if that's
what you've been taught since Year Dot
is it really their fault I think the
education system has
a lot to answer for yeah I think the the
way we're teaching kids primary
secondary and University I think we've
got a real problem a new University
Professor yourself I we are not exposing
students to a diverse range of views
beliefs and perspectives we are not
developing critical thinking
as much as we should I think covert
exacerbated this I think the lockdown
also exacerbated this I think we have in
the universities we've been far too
quick to embrace online learning remote
learning whereby the interactions with
students have become
pretty minimal actually many
universities have carried on using the
practices they developed during covert
hybrid learning Blended learning so the
social interaction aspects of university
life where you are exposed to those
different views and beliefs has become
much less visible much less regular I
think that's contributed to it too but
also to be blunt the politicization of
Institutions I mean if you look at the
the ratio of left to to right academics
and from the 1960s it's gone from three
to one to closer to ten to one so if you
are a student your the likelihood of
your meeting
a professor who isn't kind of radically
progressive or or just very socially
liberal is is minimal I mean it is
unlikely
um so I think that's contributed to it
as well and then we've got all of the
evidence of self-sense
self-censorship on campus where we know
from the surveys about 40 of students
now say I'm not going to share My Views
because I'm scared of the impact that
will have on my social networks or my
reputation because we're now in this
kind of culture whereby you know you
will lose status and friends and
standing if you are seen to endorse
particular views and I I do think the
institutions have a lot to answer for I
mean gender identity theory is a great
example of that I mean we are being
asked to
Embrace something that is a belief
system it's not fact it's not science
it's a belief system and some people
will support it and others don't and if
you don't you should be allowed to say I
don't believe in this I'm not going to
use gender pronouns I'm not going to use
this language I'm not going to embrace
this vocabulary
um
but many people feel they can't do that
but it isn't it also their duty to push
back because if no one pushes back then
the ideology just runs rampant yeah but
what do you do if you don't have
Financial Security or you don't have
seniority I cannot tell you Francis how
many emails I've had from Junior
academics who have already spent 10
years making no money studying for a PhD
doing a postdoc trying to get one of the
very few positions that are available
and have then come into universities
have often been horrified at the extent
to which
they are openly political I mean there's
political Insignia everywhere what do
you mean by political Insignia I mean it
is well I mean in the same way that you
walk into the National Health Service
and you realize that
it's a political project I mean there's
from lanyards to Flags to posters I mean
it is a sort of it's an experiment in
cultural in sort of almost revolutionary
spirit is in the air I mean it is quite
remarkable you know flags hanging around
and it's it's it's kind of interesting
um but uh junior academics I think are
coming into these institutions and
saying well if I want to get job
security if I want to make Professor I
can't really say what I think so they're
not going to talk administrators aren't
going to talk because they want to
expand a lot of the diversity Equity
inclusion bureaucracy because it's good
for them sort of justifies positions so
recently Florida
um it was really it was revealed that
public university state universities in
Florida are now spending 35 million
dollars every year on diversity Equity
inclusion initiatives 35 million uh
Michigan
um spending 18 million which is
equivalent to sending about a thousand
kids through college to get degrees so
this has become a massive industry as
you know so the administrators don't
really have any incentive the vice
chancellors don't really have any
incentive to change it because they're
deriving status and they've got all of
these internal pressures to keep doing
it uh and so the whole thing kind of
continues to carry on
um meanwhile we are routinely
prioritizing ideology above the things
that universities were set up to do
which is search for truth to be
objective to study
subjects you know in a in a in a
rigorous way because now social justice
is a priority so if you want to apply
for a job you submit a diversity
statement which you have a page of A4
and you have to explain to me how you
are committed to diversity if you want
to apply for a research Grant which you
need to win grants to be successful in
universities in order to do that you
have to write a diversity statement you
have to tell me why you believe in these
in the goals of this political project
you have to tell me in what way have you
Advanced the goals of diversity equity
and inclusion this is political this is
openly political
um but it's happening at every major
university no one has a problem with
this right I've surveyed academics 60 of
academics say they support this it's a
good idea
universities are not supposed to be
political projects schools are not
supposed to be political projects great
but that's unfortunately what they've
become and that explains very much the
new Elite and how it's becoming more and
more uh culturally entrenched and more
dominant over time because if you go to
university and and this is what you are
exposed to then of course you're more
likely to end up being that way in the
long run so it might be a flip back to
that though yeah
you've also made this point that maybe
if this becomes the Orthodoxy and also
culturally it's very boring yes you know
and kids
Zuma students or gen alpha or whoever's
coming next I suspect there will be a
generation that comes along and thinks
this is just really Naf you know it's
going to be cool to kind of cool some of
this stuff out and also I think the
evidence is going to undermine it you
know we are on the cusp of developments
with genetic coding
um and science that are going to be
complete game changers in how we
understand Health Medicine life
expectancy all of that stuff so the idea
that there are not
inherent differences between groups is
just going to be completely
unsustainable I mean it already is if
you look at the evidence that over the
next five to ten years it's just going
to look utterly ridiculous there's a lot
of This research and evidence comes
through Matt should the government step
in because if this is going on and as
you say and look I fully believe you
that this is what is happening shouldn't
the government step in these are
publicly funded institutions if they're
being overtly political
then someone needs to be done some type
of Reform the government is stepping in
I mean the one good thing that the Boris
Johnson conservative government did was
bring the higher education academic
freedom bill which will do two things it
will require universities to
protect and promote academic freedom
and secondly it will create an
independent body that academics who are
being persecuted like Kathleen stock and
others can go to and essentially sue the
university for harassing them because of
their political views now a lot of um
liberal conservatives have spent the
last two years saying well you know this
is unnecessary we don't need this
then why people getting sacked why are
people getting harassed why are people
getting discriminated against that
legislation is about to receive Royal
assent in 2023 that will become the
first significant pushback against
wokism in higher education in the
Western World Sweden is watching us
Quebec is watching us America is
watching us uh and in that sense I think
actually you know I'm an optimist I do
think that will make a big difference
nothing moves universities like the fear
of being sued and also League tables you
create a league table for academic
freedom and commitment to free speech
every University will want to be at the
top of it so I do think culturally we
can begin to to change things and you
might think I'm being naive but I do
genuinely think the fight is not over
which is why I would just say I've
always opposed the idea of setting up
parallel institutions because I think
it's too early to leave the Legacy
institutions you know this move in
America to set up entirely new
universities
I think it's too early to be retreating
from the old ones I think you know I
think the fight is still on I think it
depends on the institution I mean
obviously not to compare ourselves to to
to a national broadcaster but you're
kind of participating in a small part of
a set of new institutions uh that are on
alternative to the to the mainstream
media
um and in terms of mainstream comedy and
all of these things I mean they they're
eating themselves out from the inside
and so uh I think it really depends but
a university is a very big project I
agree yeah
um and it'd be interesting to see how
that that fight plays out I mean
Christopher roofer who we've had on the
show there's a lot of debate about what
he's doing
um and uh it's just interesting to watch
how these things are gonna Chris Ruffo
is in in some ways a mirror image of the
people that he is campaigning against
and I don't mean that in a in an
insulting way but what he has shown is
what you can do if you are highly
organized well resourced connected uh
and highly active and we tend to forget
this but take Britain and I talk about
this in the book The woke percentage of
the population right is about 15 and so
you know it's a significant number but
they're very much in the minority but
when you look at how they spend their
days always on social media five times
more active on Twitter and Facebook
constantly churning out you know the
belief system like just there every day
racism racism discrimination White
Privilege white you know the whole thing
just out there all the time very active
and so moderates often feel sort of you
know under pressure as if they can't
speak as if you know God look there's so
many of them they're everywhere
um but actually they're a very small
group but rufo I think is shown in a
different way to the right I think he's
shown them what you can achieve if you
are highly organized and also
financially the independent right I mean
that's a crucial point I remember having
this conversation with uh Jordan
Peterson who made the argument that you
can only really get seriously involved
in quote unquote the culture War if you
are completely independent from the
Legacy institutions because otherwise
you know they'll destroy you and then
you've got nowhere to go so lots of
people who I know have been doing you
know outspoken things who have been
contrarian
um have only done that after getting
themselves into positions which meant
they were essentially uncancelable and
and there is a strategy that I think you
do that is a strategy you have to pursue
Matt it's been great having you back
really recommend everybody grab the book
Thank You values voice and virtue
appreciate it thanks for coming back as
you well know uh we always have a final
question which is what's the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be
great question
um what's hap this is going to start off
weird what's happening to young women I
think yeah I think is is really
interesting if you look at all the data
on Young University educated women
something weird is happening they are
not only outperforming their male
counterparts at every part in every part
of the education system but they are
also moving sharply to the left
politically and culturally and I think
this is going to be one of the really
big interesting Trends to watch play out
over the next
um
20 30 years because it's going to have
all kinds of effects I think men and
women are going to move in quite
different directions politically and
culturally but I also think for society
we're going to be left with
a group of men who have not gone to the
university system who are very
culturally conservative maybe quite
populist in their Outlook
who will also perhaps struggle to be
to be connected to wider society and and
may not be seen by women as as a
particularly enticing Prospect and that
also will have lots of effects there you
go there's a recipe for social careers
and let me just say just before I go
it's been a delight to watch uh the show
blowing up and it's been a delight to
watch the reaction to your Oxford Union
talk and uh the successes deserved so
congratulations thanks so much you were
here from the early days actually I
remember you coming to uh what would
have been our second studio in in a in a
very hot sweat box small uh Studio
don't tell them about that you're taking
your top off yeah no uh it was great and
uh you know you're one of our favorite
guests whenever anything big happens in
British politics we're always Keen to
get you on but I hope everyone gets your
book I really enjoyed reading it uh
thank you guys for watching we're gonna
obviously as always ask Matt a couple of
questions from our supporters that
they've already submitted that only they
will get to see that answers to but for
now thank you for watching and listening
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one oral
show all of them go out at 7 pm UK time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
leave the right wing manifestation by
the mainstream media
[Music]